live in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Parker and Kara are with us welcome guys
Merry Christmas mrs. Steve now this is
always special when we have a debt free
scream in the lobby every MC solutions
it's always super special when it's one
of our own team members yes sir and and
a new team member just a couple of
months you've been with us right Parker
that's correct
well tell America what you do for Ramsey
solutions I'm a stewardship advisor
so I'm putting financial peace and other
stewardship programs into churches
working with churches all over America
which we have tens of thousands of them
teaching the different classes Financial
Peace University legacy journey smart
money smart kids classes and so on and
so that's what you're doing every day
very cool and Kara what do you do I'm an
administrative kind of a assistant
administrator at a place here in
Nashville okay very cool good for you
and you guys just after starting here
just here two months now you're going to
do your debt-free scream so how much
have you paid off paid off thirty two
thousand one hundred and sixty seven
dollars and 32 cents uh-huh
we know whose administrative okay and
how long did that take you took us 19
months okay and I won't ask what you
guys make since Parker works here and a
bunch of his contemporaries are standing
around that's not fair to put you on the
spot and do that we make everybody else
do that you know that but uh but so what
kind of debt was the 32,000 just my
student loans so Cary you married into
student loan debt huh you guys been
married just over a year
oh okay so you've been working on this
since before marriage then okay fine
fine so tell me the story what is the
journey like over this nineteen months
what happened that caused you to do this
and and would you do well we also we
cashflow the wedding during that time as
well and so I was kind of saving towards
that while Parker was starting to pay
off the debt okay and we just once we
got married we combined our finances we
just started attacking it and he's going
all-in and we were able to pay it off
and about the time we have planned on
paying it off so that was awesome I
worked out great yeah surprised so how
did all this get started Parker she was
kind of paying off her debts that she
had before we were married so I was
watching from a distance and saying
that's really great but that's not me
mm-hmm
in my mountains a lot bigger and it's
just going to have to be a way different
way and I can't get nearly as intense
for that long once we started to talk
about marriage I realized that that was
kind of going to be the terms I accepted
my fate from there okay Google so Carol
what got you so fired up about getting
out of that well my parents took your
class back when I was like 20 years old
they told me about it and they said you
know I wish we would have known about
this when we were your guys as a jury
would be rich right now mm-hmm
and so I picked up your book and I just
kind of thought oh I just I'm just gonna
pay off just a little bit of my dad I
had a student loan a small student loan
and a car loan and I picked up your book
and I read it that weekend and I was
just I mean it was like a switch flipped
and so how do we end up hiring him as
too big a mountain and we end up hiring
him to sell it for you you know it's
contagious and when you start seeing
progress and you focus on one thing at a
time and see that progress and start
realizing it's possible it's more
rewarding than any anything money can
buy no I remember him saying oh you're
not actually poor you're just acting
like you're poor and once I got my debt
paid off it was like oh you have you
actually do have this money well you'll
be able to take the video from this now
Parker and show the people you're
calling on at these churches did you
really did it right yes sir I plan on it
very cool less fun becomes a selling aid
here yeah this is good
so you better make your scream really
visceral and good
that's cool so what is your advice to
other young couples that are sitting
back there they're dating and they're
talking about getting married and they
feel like they're overwhelmed Parker
let's start with you because you kind of
felt overwhelmed that mountain was too
big and you got some inspiration to
tackle it anyway what's your advice to
them on getting out of that what do you
tell them the secret is in a
relationship it's the teamwork aspect of
it there's something about your partner
having a weak moment and it just makes
you Alton stronger so it's it's the
teamwork aspect or the accountability
partner that really gets it through when
the setbacks come and Murphy comes in to
keep driving
just keep pushing okay cool what about
you Carol I would just say just keeping
the angle in mind knowing where you're
wanting to end up and for me I had
already seen that other side so I think
when we had said we want to pay this off
and you know the first year and a half
of our marriage our first two years of
our marriage I knew how that felt and so
it was easier for me when things were
hard to just say no let's just keep
going you know and when we were ready to
give up just try to remember where
you're getting to and even now the way
we sit in our jobs and and I mean even
moving here we were called to come here
and we were able to do that because we
had we had this peace with our finances
and so I mean that is such a valuable
thing to just spend you're here your
money and your your effort on is just
getting to that end goal of being in
control and telling your money where to
go instead of being controlled by by
your things by your stuff no Parker I
was telling a group of leaders the other
day that one of the ways we know we've
done a good hire is if they have married
up so you are a good hire yes well done
well done you guys alright Parker from
our team and Kara $32,000 paid off in 19
months making a mystery amount of money
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream ready three two why
love it love it well Don you too
very well done you guys would be so rich
so fast and be able to do so much not
only for yourselves and for your family
but for others